these are basically the skittles of
torito's okay we're about to try these
rainbow rainbow Doritos they look so
happy so when you donate to the It Gets
Better campaign you get a bag of rainbow
Doritos and so we got some to try
I heard that rainbow Doritos or making
conservative groups angry I'm glad I
came out just so I can like the only gay
people look at these or something all
right oh they're smaller than it'll be
the soup flavor profiles pretty standard
Dorito flavor and smell they are the
core I think they're good they're not
bad it's like normal I think they taste
like Doritos
I'm personally I'm a fan of unnatural
colors and food and if you throw them up
it's kind of like that new snapchat
filter it's just like what's
disappointing is that the powder is not
the color of the chip which was really
what I wanted a visual representation on
the bag doesn't match what's actually in
the bag I think this is your purple
that's not purple they're adorable
and I like them is this bag of Doritos
worth $10 it's $10 no no you should
donate laughs yeah like it's a great
cause and you should donate but like one
thing like Doritos can toss in like two
bags I think if you're like are spending
your time hating on chips you have some
deep deeper deep set problems it's 2015
if you're not Pro rainbow Dorito you're
on the wrong side of history so you got
to get with it